you and i last time when we were
speaking i think we talked about i told
you the story about my friend who we
went to this gay bar in nashville and
the guy says how do you know you're not
gay that's right and the entire drive
back is like how do i know how do you
know how do you know it's like he can't
ever try that's messing with my head and
he had to find out for him something
like you don't need to find out
and i got to do my research like a
professor here i got to get that tenure
he had to go figure it out for himself
that he's not and it was like such a
weird thing to go through it's like no
i'm not gay i'm like you honestly you
have to do that to kind of go through
imagine doing that justify you guys good
news i'm not gay but you know yeah me
and the buddy down there can you imagine
that story right there so i'm like okay
but then i asked you a question i said
so let me ask you do you think
with all these tv shows like yes last
night we're sitting in the uh at the
house uh uh morals in town and we're
having conversations all this stuff and
hey what movie you watch all this stuff
and
you know we're talking about jurassic
park the one that just came out which
honestly whoever's going to be offended
by this it is what it is one of the
worst movies i've seen
in the last few years well when all the
dinosaurs are gay and trans what do you
expect just horrible okay
and then you watch top gun it's better
than top gun one anyways so then we look
at cartoons for kids so the new cartoon
is a toy story guy what's the guy's name
lightyear
yeah and you know in there there is a
character where uh there's a lgbt
characters that they're kissing each
other and they're holding the baby okay
in a cartoon
and originally
the ceo the company said we're not gonna
do this we're gonna cut this because
this is too much
and the employees
at disney pixar
came out protesting where they finally
said leave it in there so it's in the
cartoon right
so i'm sitting there and we're having a
conversation whether we're gonna watch
this with our kids or not whether we're
gonna watch this with our kids
i said there's no benefit for me to
watch this i said if you want to watch
porn whatever kind of kinky porn you
like to i don't know what kind of porn
you watch whatever you watch
give it to yourself you don't need to
put it in a movie for me to watch and
then it's my choice you know i don't
know what his choice for porn is he's
expressed it a few times you know it's
usually men in purple wigs that's my
kind of thing these days i don't know
with a big basketball player in front of
him
but but the point is i said i said it's
a little too much where you're selling
too many things to my kids and i'm out
of it and i asked you i said yeah do you
think
all these shows all these movies are
making us
or making kids increase the population
of the lgbtq community and you said no i
don't think it's affecting it as much as
it is
and then bill maher three weeks ago
comes out if you can post that one
picture of what bill maher put
he says at this pace within the next 20
years we're all going to be gay is what
he said because the percentage of if you
can zoom that in that's actually very
interesting he says the silent
generation only point eight percent are
gay
the baby boomer generation only 2.6
percent gen x
is 4.2 millennials 10.5 gen z
one out of five gen z is part of the l
they they see themselves as part of the
lgbt identification it's lgbtq
what's causing it so i can i can maybe
tease it up tease it out a bit tease it
a part of it uh
to to try to be gay in so for example if
i'm a man and i want to be cool and be
part of a fad it's going to be involve
sodomy in dark corners that takes a lot
of behavioral commitment on my part you
follow what i'm saying on the other hand
if i just have to self-identify as trans
that's not nearly as much of a
behavioral commitment right so so one
could could be prone to a fad
the latter one whereas the former one
it's very unlikely that i'm just going
to get into anonymous gay sex because
it's fetish to do so
to speak to your point to the point of
your friend who who didn't know if he
was gay or not i know if i'm interested
in turkish guys and gay saunas right so
i don't think that so so there's a paper
by the way by a i think she was a
pediatrician and i i i mentioned her in
uh the parasitic mind her name was lisa
littman
uh are you do you know her do you know
so she wrote a paper in plus one which
is an academic journal
where she was exactly arguing in much
more scientific terms what bill maher is
arguing there that the trans uh move or
phenomenon is really one of a social
contagion
right now that makes sense right because
if i'm a young kid who you know is
feeling a bit uh
ostracized i can get a lot of ego
strokes by belonging to a group today
that feels fadish that doesn't require
much behavioral investment and on my
part to simply say you know i may be
self-identifying as a girl or a boy
whatever it might be i think it's a lot
harder to be fattish about your sexual
behavior right and especially if you're
a man so for example we do know from
research that women are a lot more
sexually fluid in other words it makes a
lot more sense to for a woman to say you
know in college i dabbled whereas it's a
lot harder for pat and i to say you know
in college when we were watching an nfl
game then we started wrestling with each
other and then and then sodomy broke out
so so when it comes to to men i think
there's a lot less fluidity i really
know if i'm gay or not for women it's a
lot more fluid and the trans craze for
many kids who identify as trans it's
really because it's just fetish now by
the way lisa lippman
when she published the paper did you
guys put it up
oh yeah exactly when she published the
paper i right away reached out to her
because at first it was published and
then it caused all kinds of problems and
then they wanted to retract it so i
invited her on my show
because i'm always the guy who invites
all these folks who are otherwise
getting brutalized by everybody else and
no academic is courageous enough to
invite them and she wrote back to me
saying look i would love to thank you so
much for the offer but she was scared at
the time
because she thought she just wanted it
to die
you know the story to die away but i
think it's never a good idea to do that
because the once the you know the
blue-haired taliban comes after you
they're going to come after you no
matter what so if you try to placate
them if you try to apologize it's never
going to work quick story about not
apologizing
and actually you just met my wife so
this is a story about my wife so we had
got your hot wife my hot wife thank you
we had gone to a
cafe a local cafe that we always go to
in montreal and my wife had just met
this new barista who looked as though
they were transgender so she came back
to me and said you know you know god i
felt very uncomfortable because i don't
want to say something that would offend
that person i didn't know how to address
them and so i wrote out a tweet where i
said
you know she was frozen in fear not sure
about what to say because she don't want
to hurt the person's feelings that tweet
was meant to demonstrate how empathetic
and kind she was that she was so
unsure of how to handle them
26 million tweet impressions later and
two three days of millions of mob coming
after me including valerie bertinelli
you know the the former child actress
who basically said my wife is mentally
they completely misconstrued the tweet
the tweet was about
my wife didn't want to say something
that would hurt that person's feelings
she was being empathetic she was being
persecuted because she didn't want to
call them by the wrong pronoun by the
wrong pronoun okay uh so i could have
easily taken down the tweet i could have
apologized what did i do being the king
of all honey badgers i then satirized
their [ __ ] i did you guys know the
series that i do under under the table
yeah under the desk yeah so this is this
is where i mock the idea that you know
i'm always afraid right donald trump has
just become president i'm hiding uh you
know brett kavanaugh just became just as
i'm hiding
so i hate i hid under the table and i
said that unlike
the isis folks that i had to run from in
lebanon in the mid 70s
the pronoun taliban are incredibly
scarier than the guys that i ran away
from in lebanon so what i did is i
mocked their hysteria i waited out i
didn't apologize for anything and guess
what they got bored and went away so
life lesson guys unless you really have
something to apologize for
never apologize so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]